Selena Gomez shares a snippet of her new  single fetish look in the moon but not  look in the mirror baby I feel clear why  you wanna be near the singer first  teased her new song in May at the end of  her bad liar music video and last week  the 24 year old shared three stills from  the upcoming video on Instagram  each captioned with the title of the  song  [Music]  she has since shared several other  images revealing the release date will  be Thursday July 13th but on Tuesday  Selena gave fans their first listen to  the single posting a snippet to  Instagram but now look at me baby su  clear what you want to be here when et  caught up with Selena in March she  dished on her upcoming album I think  people are gonna be a little surprised  I'm excited for what's coming and these  days Selena has a lot to sing about in  April she told ET she's in a really good  place but everything you know my  personal life and  friends I'm just a really happy place  it's been good  [Music]  you